rose Tico fans contain mercury well sort
of an alleged summary of the Star Wars
rights of Skywalker script has emerged
on YouTube from a former professional
screenplay reader named Robert Burnett
this supposed version of the script is
said to have been written during Colin
Trevor Rose time in the director's chair
before he lost his job in 2017 and the
entire project started over with the
force awakens director JJ Abrams back at
the helm this script with the working
title the doll of the faith's appears to
be a profoundly different movie from the
one we received in December 2019 though
several of the individual concepts are
similar enough they might have been
repurposed for the rise of Skywalker the
story itself however is entirely
different and Kelly Marie trans Rose
Tico is at its core I work my pipes all
day do you mean talking with resistance
heroes it's not my forte I'm Ruth funds
of Rose who was introduced in the last
Jedi have been upset by how the rise of
Skywalker minimised their presence and
insulted the character on top of the
real-life irassman tron experience on
social media because of her role they
can perhaps find some bittersweet
comfort in the possibility that
somewhere along the line someone might
have cared about rose however we can't
100% guarantee that the alleged script
described in the video is genuine
Burnett's explains straight away that he
won't provide proof of the script beyond
craft images of the title page and the
original narration crawl or any detail
as to how he got a hold of it but if you
want to imagine this is legit hey go for
it let's take a look at the version of
Rose Tico in the rise of Skywalker that
might have been the alleged original
rise of Skywalker script actually opens
on Rose Tico and bb-8 a good chunk of
the first actors are attempting along
with Finn
Poe and eventually Rey to sabotage the
transportation of or use for building
Star Destroyers are the kouachi
shipyards
long story short the sabotage goes very
poorly for our heroes but with luck they
escape are you ready for this by jacking
an entire freaking star destroyer off
the lot and peeling out of the shipyards
at Lightspeed all the wild roses
described as being front and center
doing her best to reorganize from plans
a B and Z all fail there are two major
teams performing missions and his
alleged script
rape oh and Chewbacca take off on their
own
they're half while rose Finn c-3po and
r2d2 depart for chorus Santa try a
desperate gamble in trying to snuff out
the resistance for good the first order
has choked off all inter system
communication at its source ray learns
from the tech she picked up in the last
Jedi however that the Jedi Temple houses
a giant's Kyber crystal that the Old
Republic used thousands of years ago as
a communication system the first order
doesn't have the means to control
lighting this ancient beacon is the last
hope of the resistance to gather allies
Andros takes points on this do-or-die
mission once the beacons subplot is
completed on chorus on the alleged
rights of Skywalker script continues on
into the city itself since the fall of
the Republic as we knew it in a Star
Wars prequel trilogy the city planet has
taken a major hit with most citizens
falling in to scavenging and
homelessness frozen Finn navigators
underclass and eventually help incite
the revolts you heard the right the
woman who lost her family she had left
in a civil war gets to assist inciting
the biggest on-screen popular revolt
against fascism in Star Wars in chorus
and boy to climax this all takes place
while a massive battle occurs in orbit
over chorus arts with genuine layers
forces united by Lando Calrissian the
cherry on top is mentioned in passing by
Burnett as he wraps up the video once
the first order is defeated the
remaining leadership attempt to flee
from Coruscant and a giant mobile
headquarters at some point in the story
that Burnett doesn't describe gross
messes with the compounds navigation
computers and when the complex goes to
Lightspeed the travel vectors are
incorrect and it crashes into a planet
destroying the order for good it's not
as elegant as a one-in-a-million shot
into an exhaust ports but that is wicked
call sadly since there's no proof that
any of that is actually true you could
have to take it with a grain of salt in
fact though it might have existed at one
point fans of Rose might rather pretend
the screenplay drafted didn't after all
wall it would be as a reminder of
something they got cheated out of the
past three years have been tumultuous
for the Star Wars franchise between the
backlash over the last Jedi and failure
Solo and Trevor Rose professional merit
seemed to have dropped after his film
book of Henry
totally bombed at the box office being
the poster boy for the biggest franchise
on earth must have been
lots of pressure at the time and it
appears that maybe in the end a bunch of
fallible humans cracked underneath it
despite the mixed overall response to
the rise of Skywalker many people did in
fact enjoy it and that's the legacy of
Star Wars as a whole it's too many
things too many people and there's no
way in hell it could ever please
everybody check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one